[Music]
if you've happened upon one of the other
cable news networks recently first of
all disk disk well you've probably been
barred with updates on former Trump
campaign share Paul man affords federal
trial kicked off today despite no
allegations of Russian collusion man
affords facing serious prison time in a
case brought by the special counsel Bob
Muller it's all related to Manta for its
work for Russia friendly Ukrainian
political party there that predated his
time of the Trump campaign so I got
swept up in this whole deal
interestingly enough though there are
now reports that Muller has referred
three cases to federal prosecutors in
Manhattan involving high-profile
lobbyists who also worked on behalf of
that same Ukrainian linked group without
registering though as foreign agents
haven't heard much about that heavier
could it be that because well one of
those names is Tony Podesta super
lobbyist in the Democratic Party and
brother of John the chairman of
Hillary's failed 2016 campaign or that
other name Greg Craig he's a former
White House Counsel for Barack Obama
rejoining us now for reaction Alan
Dershowitz and soullow Eisenberg okay
guys how potentially serious or not is
this deal with referring both Podesta
and Greg Craig to the Southern District
of New York
Greg Craig full disclosure worked for my
old law firm of Skadden Arps and they
parted ways months back but let's start
with you professor Dershowitz what's
going on here
well Greg's a great guy he lives on
Martha's Vineyard with me I see him
periodically over the summer
full disclosure look this just proves
that you never needed a special counsel
they're taking these cases more and more
of them referring them to ordinary US
Attorney's Office the the metaphor case
also could have easily been tried by the
US Attorney's Office in Northern
Virginia the other mana 4 case by the
District of Columbia US Attorney's
Office why do we need a special counsel
the cases don't involve Russia for the
most part the only cases that involve
Russia are cases that'll never be tried
at all the 12 Russians they're not
coming to Disneyland any day soon to be
served and they're not going to be
extradited by by Vladimir Putin so we're
seeing more and more
proof that we never needed a special
counsel that the special counsel will
end up filing a report and getting some
low-hanging fruit and getting some
convictions largely unrelated to what
his mandate originally was I didn't like
special counsel when they were appointed
to get Bill Clinton I didn't like them
in in other cases I don't like them now
I don't think but similar saw what's
interesting we're vacuuming or vacuuming
up a lot of information about people and
it's going it's going up to the special
the Southern District of New York same
deal with Michael Cohen it's it does
seem like it's expanding to places that
have nothing to do with the original
charge well two things in my view number
one I think probably if it's really gone
to the Southern District unlike Cohen
where they could say this is just not in
our bailiwick here this was part of the
original manna fourth thing but I think
probably they're gonna decline those
cases and it's just my guess and that if
Muller declined cases against Democrats
he would get a tremendous amount of
criticism for it so it's easier to say
Southern District it looks better from
Muller who's been accused by the
president correctly years of having 17
which I don't it's just he should the
president shouldn't be doing that but
here's the other thing here's the
difference right or wrong Muller sees
man afford is a key to his Russia
conspiracy case he believes right or
wrong that man affort knows something
and man afford is the key and that's why
he's going after manna for it and he's
clearly gonna try and judge now let's
say that today and he said I don't like
it but the system lets him do it and and
every prosecutor has done that at some
point in their career so that's the key
to Muller manna Ford is the key the
question will be is if he's convicted
does he become like Susan mcdougal and
say nuts to you I'm still not talking to
you or does he actually decide he'd
rather talk than spend if he has any
information
he's there for five minutes at the Trump
campaign I mean I don't think Trump is
worried he moved all about Paul Manafort
I know for a fact he's not worried about
there's one he made a very good point
though you made a very important point
and that is it's much easier for you as
attorney to decline a case and that's
why we should have US attorneys their
professional prosecutors and they don't
have a target and they can decline cases
if the facts and the law don't want
prosecution okay it's hard for a special
counsel I'll do that okay let's advance
this narrative though today we have this
trial kicking off in the Eastern
District of New York and it struck me
that much of the time in this in these
opening statements a lot of the
conversation went to Paul manna for its
wealth and there was one point where
they brought in this witness okay
maximilien Katzman former manager of a
New York City men's wear store called
Alan Kutcher claiming Manta Ford spent
more than nine hundred and twenty nine
thousand on suits between 2010 and 2014
judge Ellis then says cantankerous old
judge Ellis who I loved dearly all this
document shows is that mr. manna Ford
had a lavish lifestyle he had a nice
home with a pool and a gazebo it's not
relevant of course he went on to make a
really funny comment about the clothes
saying and you've spent a lot on clothes
and it wasn't even that well dressed I
mean it's a crime nowadays spend a lot
of money we got a lot of people guilty
of that in this town the judge also said
if it doesn't say Men's Wearhouse I
don't know anything about oh I see that
figure that's my that's my kind of judge
that's my kind of judge I'll never be
convicted of anything
if expensive clothing are a prerequisite
I also go to Men's Warehouse yeah the
interesting thing about that is that
under the law the prosecute the law is
terrible on showing lavish lifestyle
under the law the prosecutors in most
courts would be allowed to say that but
judge Ellis really doesn't like it and
every time he makes those comments the
jury is listening to him and they know
that he doesn't like it yeah presser
Dershowitz at one point they talked
about the fact that man afford used
foreign wire transfers to pay for his
clothes and this maximilien cat's men
who's like the
kaylynn of the trial so far he says he
says well that's the only customer I've
ever had pay for it who cares I mean I
guess this is not against the law I
don't know what manna fort did I think
this whole thing I don't know my antenna
my spidey senses are going up about this
case I don't know if it's Rick Gates I
don't know if they're afraid to bring
rick gates into as a prosecution witness
they seem to be hesitant about bringing
gates in which i find interesting
professor well whenever you have a
witness who's admitted to lying it's a
very hard job to put him on the stand
and the witness always says well I lied
in the past yes I know that but now I'm
telling the truth
and then the lawyer for the defense's
will you expect to benefit from telling
the truth don't you you expect to get a
good deal so you know it's very hard to
get a successful conviction based on a
flip witness who might not only be
singing but composing and this judge is
very sympathetic to that he used that
term he said sometimes witnesses who was
squeezed not only sing but compose and
make the case better in order to get a
better deal they talked about not doing
that early morning raid were almost out
of time early morning raid apparently
the FBI had a key to his condo and they
said how did you have a key they said we
don't know how he had the key weird oh
yeah that's that's interesting but
listen he's gonna tell gates is gonna
test case is gonna testify all right
guys this is we're gonna have you back
all the time this is gonna be
fascinating great panel great to see you
in person